the stunts you're about to see were
performed by train drivers on a closed
course do not try this at home
ready go this is third person driver
Olli here is wearing video goggles and
so is opponent Paul all they can see is
the view from this hovering hexacopter
drone which will be giving them
cinematic video game-like camera angles
here's the course down the runway
through a blind opening to the left then
round pass and worryingly solid shipping
containers no hard to see mesh fence
then a tight turn as she came back out
onto the runway at a high speed - back
to the finish line
fastest time without crushing wins and
I'm in the passenger seat as the
emergency spotter Holly lining up for
the heavy gap now once you know you've
got some clear space it's fine find a
hit a gate is in public it feels
impossible you manage it know you went
through that first gap at speed
yeah I didn't really mean to though all
trying the same gap taking a line much
further to the left and hoping to go in
well still turning these pulled way too
far the leftovers head up the divider Oh
just straight through it's so disarming
not knowing the angle of your current
turn you usually have an idea when
driving visually of how much further you
need to turn there's no feedback at all
both drivers thought there was a lag on
the video feed to their goggles there
wasn't it's just the brain isn't set up
to deal with this ollie coming in a
little close on the right there please
pull it back remember they're not seeing
the glorious HD picture you've got to
their eyes the view looks more like a
gameboy held at arm's length that wire
mesh fence is almost invisible it's
nothing so I thought this would be easy
round burn nicely though the view isn't
perfect you don't things directly enough
it's headed for the concrete court
emergency stop cover and simply changing
work from the passenger seat that is
going to cost Ollie time all attempting
the same corner now you have no idea how
far through the corner you are not even
from g-forces by the time the video feed
says you're complete you've gone too far
and you've got a worried passenger I
reckon if I straighten up now yeah
that's a lovely bit of cornering Paul's
exactly on the line
pretty good through the chicane now and
that's pretty much spot-on to good
recovery afterwards I'll be tries to
chicane that lines good to start with
but he doesn't need to turn that far
he's now almost 90 degrees away from
where he needs to be actually you need
to go left
honestly it's hilarity good fun it's
just really like radio oli starts to put
his foot down for the final run but if
we compare the two drives you can see
that Paul's already going into much
higher speed he's only going to
accelerate from here bit more confidence
bit more of a lead foot either way it
doesn't matter it's a clear victory all
those a bit of a wobble there as the
drone shows him where he needs to go
doesn't matter he's over the line for 30
seconds but that is still a good man how
do you feel that's fantastic
you